onto page
marauder dory
the process
okay
the process is very important because
footwork is very important
as in tana hinka
and um
tanahenka and maro tutori footwork is
going to be in many
uh technical movements in aikido
in the tanahanka
that's
going onto the marauder doorway there's
things that you don't always see
and that they go on inside the person
so
my elbow
what you don't see in tanjenko is a
subtle movement
that is the elbow drops
that way
okay
come closer to the camera just so you
can see the elbow
so
get out the hand turns
the elbow see that elbow softening
that elbow is actually going off there
if you are the camera
and you're at 12 o'clock
my fingers are pointing at six o'clock
see where the elbow's going it's going
off at about two o'clock
about two o'clock
and then it comes back
so it goes
like a
elliptical movement
why am i explaining that now and i
didn't explain it in time
you have to be careful
you start doing that you could start
leaning forward
leaning forward you can you can start to
add faults that weren't there before
when i teach yoga i say to people
go inside yourself and
mentally relax that part
and it's not always seen by the naked
eye of another
but the person feels it inside so this
is what you should be doing here
it softens
but that softening
means that it's going
a slight angle
you need to understand this from the
righty dory
person comes to take your arm
they take it down the aim is for them to
have a little tension so
you can't
move
back this way you can't twist your elbow
you can't kick them
else they apply
a sort of a yonk yo but that's the angle
of the armpit
their movement is
that way
as they start to take down about here
you need to stimulate
that feeling
as they start to take down you follow
them you let them take it but then you
catch up with them
and you take over
that feeling i'm moving the foot just to
show you but you may move the foot you
may not move the foot you may just go
like this
but when you energize remember there's a
difference between energizing and
stiffness
okay
so puff yourself up
okay because
it's not strength
it's not limp
like this and then you have to come from
a cold start into dynamics
so they power you up they motorize you
this is what you want me on this feeling
now i'm going to talk about the elbow
you take it down there
this one is very complex because it
looks like this
a step behind
a straightening of the front leg
the turning of the hips
the turning of the torso
and you only put your hands out
for no other reason
than to save you getting kicked in the
face and this is why you look the other
way
no other reason the arms do not
absolutely nothing everybody thinks that
they they have to
throw
the person with their arms you don't
you should be able to do this straighten
the leg turn the hips torso and if this
is all correct this leg is all correct
they will just fall over
over that
leg you don't need to do anything with
the arms if you can do that then you
know
you're doing it without
the strength of your upper body
now here's a contradiction
it looks like
i'm coming into them
into them
turning my hips
stepping behind them
straighten the front leg turn
the
the hips the upper body comes out
he's not the foot my turn
it may not
sometimes we
we offer it here
and they just take it
there but this is the basic
take down
elbow now
same
as the tana anchor has a little
subtleness of going off at two o'clock
remembering the turner hanger i said you
can move the feet
you can move
the feed if you wish
okay
or you don't need to move the feet
each time you do it will be have a
different result
it will be depending on where you are
you can't say exactly every time with
each person you're going to do repeat
the same we're trying to repeat the same
but sometimes there'll be a little foot
need moving or or something will need
just adding
to make you comfortable it's not so much
the technique you need to be natural and
comfortable
you don't want to go too far outside the
parameters of the technique by being
yourself you do need to also look for
what works for you
this is a complete contradiction now to
what you think is going on
remember about the yoga
so they take you down
my arm now
is as if they were holding a bokken but
upside down so if you can watch the
curve the balkan would be that way up
normally wouldn't it
they were holding it
and i'm turning it so i've turned the
bottom over
if i now try to go into them
since you used to show this with a
bottom you used to push it and say you
can't go this way
because it's
you know their strength
but he used it with one finger get the
bokken and go that way
that way i'm going to show you from this
angle so since he would get
the bokken and he would push it and show
you how strong the person would hold it
and he would get the tip of the bokken
and he would go this way
it's at right angles
and he would then hold it and tip them
over and throw them down
so with right angles
and yet when you see the marauder dory
done
there's no right angles here so
there's no right
right angles where
so you so what you see is not actually
what's happening and that's why so many
people struggle with uh
understanding
marijuana it's not what it see what what
it seems
it's completely
different well that's my take on it
anyhow i'm going to try and show you
but here's the upside down balkan
i can't go into them
because of the principle of what scentsy
said so why do we look like we're going
in well we don't
this elbow is going to drop
to right angles
see
and then when i gather my body
it's gonna power them forward
power them forward
power them
forward
remember the time anchor i said you can
extend extend
but
if you
go back too far
you can't power them forward they
sometimes
dig their chin in here and you have a
job get getting them
up
to contradict this even further
before i go to right angles
before i go to
right angles
to you
i'm going to
do this
i'm going to step over here
and i'm going to draw
this with my hip so i'm going to draw it
towards me
and i'm dropping this elbow
i try to explain this in the book
okay i draw them off balance and then
just as they're losing their balance
i drop this
and
turn
that's what i'm actually doing but you
can't see that
you can't see that when i go
but i am actually
coming here
here
before i do that
so play around with it
see if you can understand what i'm
saying even with the book even with me
showing you live
um you won't understand it because it
goes against any of the pictures that
you've got in your head
but if you try
stepping out to the side
lowering the elbow you're not
moving their wrists they're there but it
tips that their balance
it's doing what since you've done with
the can
it's it's making a fulcrum
where their hands are
and they go
like this and when they're about there
you can then come in here
okay you can then get this
all right so you're doing
this and once this is broken
then you can power in
so without stepping here this is for you
to test this is for you to try on your
own
and then once you think you've worked it
out
with a partner
i'm stepping to the side
and stepping to the side
once you've worked it out
and you see that partner turning
you come in with this against their
elbow their forearm
okay
i'm going away for the tip of the balkan
i'm still going that way that way
even if you don't see me step now
and the stepping is to show you the
direction
the turning
the moving in
the footwork
without without the step now without
that step
the softening
on pulling if you like i shouldn't use
that word but i'm directing it back past
my shoulder and where this foot went
i'm thinking there with my shoulder
okay i don't think i can explain any
more than that
if you get it right they won't
they won't be able to block your put
their bulk on you so that you can't move
them
if you enter too deeply
with a big movement in
they'll block you because they're stable
you know they've got you here they're
very stable you've got to break their
balance
you've got to break their balance
okay so with the book
um
on those uh
it's marauding preparation i call this
okay and then we'll go on to the
we'll go page by page or set pages
it's uh
i've put my posted notes in it might be
a good idea for you to do the same so we
can
we can all be talking
as they say on the same page
so
the
the reading is on page eight
and it goes to page nine
okay page 10
shows you all the different
things i've discussed here
and talked about
and uh marital drawing a learning
process okay
and on page 13 is where it ends where
you see me throwing a
an uk in russia
and on page 12 it will show you just
some escapes
it's um it's about
you need needing to understand the
direction of your escape from my
rotatory
and once you learn that it gives you the
footwork to do um as it shows you here a
coat of guys
you know it will show you an arima nagi
these are all to do with how you blend
and
you know
you move
all right so it's all about footwork you
may not understand page 110
um and how
the drop of the elbow comes about i hope
this film will will help you
understand that
always please please comment ask
questions this is what i'm here for
i want everybody to
understand it
i didn't understand it until i slowly
watched over and over again psycho
scentsy doing it and i kept thinking why
is he so smooth why is he so smooth
and it's because he he will make
it just look so easy
so you have to break him down frame by
frame and i noticed that
his elbow
was actually
doing a different angle to where i saw
the whole the whole picture you know the
body does this
but the first part is
you've got to go away from the person
because you can't go in because they
block you
so the first
movement isn't in it's actually
out
away
it's actually out away and then once
you've got that turn once they've turned
that's when you go oh i can go in now
because there's no
locking there's no ken
going against this this anymore because
you've gone
to this corner this window you've gone
here
and then you go in once they've
lost
their balance
okay
so
please uh do as always i say do your
best go from one eye read that first
put put the
film on
and then just
uh you know
you can read it first if you want or
read after
or just try to remember the points
about
escaping
do not enter into their space
you cannot escape
okay you need to escape first by going
away from them
and then when they're they're tipped
like the um the picture shows on page
one eleven you can see
the okay tipped and that's
the first page picture four and five
you're seeing tips that's the time you
go in
okay the pictures just show you either
doing it or i'm already in
okay page one one
two and one one three
are pure applications once you've
learned that and what you can achieve
to do other techniques
okay
the next
page 114
uh we'll be talking about next of taina
henko foot movement of moro tinto
that'll be
the next stage of the film but let's do
one at a time
let me know your thoughts complications
i've said this before on patreon if
you're on patreon
you can do one to once
you can try it for a month two months
you don't have to continue that the high
percentage but you can have a one-to-one
for i think it's 17 18 pounds
once a month and you can we can look at
these and i can see you on zoom and say
no you're going the wrong way and i can
help you in anything you wish to to know
okay
thank you for your time
don gato got my star